imagine an ultimate road trip across the
globe on a highway along the
Equator wait there there's no Highway
along the Equator
yet so how about we build
one what would it take to construct the
longest road on
Earth how long would you spend behind
the wheel to complete this epic
journey and why would building this
highway upset
environmentalists this is what if and
here's what would happen if we built a
road around the
world there are about 64 million
kilometers of all kinds of Roads around
the globe but no single Highway Network
that can take you from New York directly
to Cape Town the hypothetical freeway
that we're about to build would easily
take you from Colombia all the way to
Indonesia combine that with some of the
existing Road systems and you might just
be able to drive anywhere in the
world but that would be a very expensive
engineering achievement because a big
part of this highway would have to be
constructed
[Music]
underwater on average it takes about 5
to 10 years to build a highway but we
wouldn't be building just any Highway we
are aiming for a 40,000 km long 2-lane
equatorial road to construct it in about
the same time frame as a normal Highway
we need to be working on different parts
of it all at the same
time our globe spanning Highway would
require about 8 million skilled workers
and some 9 .2 trillion to build yeah
those are some whopping numbers to
consider and what would it be like to
drive on
it I'd say it's pretty cool the equator
cuts through 13 countries in three
oceans let's say you start in South
America in Ecuador and travel east
through Colombia to
Brazil you'd be enjoying a humid
tropical climate and very high
temperature so make sure your car's air
conditioning is working before you leave
for the
trip you'd be passing over Mountains and
the Amazon River and if you decided to
go for a refreshing swim remember that
the Amazon's full of bloodthirsty
piranhas waiting to eat you in a matter
of
minutes just joking piranhas are
actually calm scavengers so you can go
for a swim at your own
risk your Amazonian Adventures would
just be the beginning you would soon
reach the Atlantic coast of Brazil and
you'd be about to enter the First
underwater stretch the Great Atlantic
tunnel and the view here is rather
dull finally there's
land after days of travel you would make
it to
Africa you'd be driving through the SAS
swamps and dense rainforest of gabang
and Congo and into the deserts of Kenya
and
Somalia on your way you might see
elephants gorillas buffaloes and
leopards and that would make the long
trip through the tunnel kind of worth it
but then you run out of land and you
enter another underwater tunnel This
Time It's the Great Indian
tunnel
H oh I see land
again it's Indonesia with its 17,000
Islands scattered around the equator
you'd be driving through a series of
short tunnels to cross from one Island
to another and every time you got back
on land the scenery would be
Majestic volcanic Landscapes rice fields
tropical
rainforests I bet you could use a stay
at the beach after such a long
drive okay it's time to move on to the
next tunnel the Great Pacific
Tunnel is it just me or is this one like
three times
longer uh no this is the longest
underwater stretch of the entire trip
and by the end of it you'd have a little
bonus in the form of the last exciting
spot of the highway
the Galapagos Islands a Showcase of
evolution where the most unusual forms
of life are thriving in the wild A Feast
for the eyes after that long
drive then you would drive a little
further through one last short
underwater tunnel and end up right where
you started in Ecuador hey
congratulations you made a road trip
around the
globe traveling at 100 km hour you'd
spend some 400 hours or about 17 days at
the
wheel 12 of those days you'd be stuck
inside a tunnel under the ocean with
some breaks for the night rest and
sometime to enjoy the sights the entire
travel time would add up to at least 2
months hope you can afford such a long
vacation but as much fun as this idea
sounds it would be an enormous hit on
the planet the construction of the
highway itself would disrupt ecosystems
both on land and in the ocean on top of
that during this epic trip your car
would emit almost twice as much carbon
dioxide as the average car does in a
year looks like we'll never see a
highway like that running along the
[Music]
Equator Bridges have brought people
together for thousands of years they've
challenged us as Engineers created trade
routes between countries and have
allowed us to conquer some of Earth's
most difficult Landscapes like mountains
Ravines rivers and lakes but what about
oceans could we build Bridges between
continents where would we build them and
how would they work this is what if and
here's what would happen if we buil bu
Bridges between
continents the desire to get from one
place to another has been with us for a
long time in my Greece ancient remnants
of bridges have been found dating back
to 1600
BCE we've built bridges in many
different shapes and sizes some of them
are considered works of art in Northern
India villagers have even built Living
Bridges using tree roots yet for for a
while Earth didn't need Bridges at all
it was one giant land mass called Pangia
but over time earth's tectonic plates
began to shift and Pangia split into
chunks forming the continents we know
today with so many land masses separated
from each other Bridges became a
necessity the desire to connect to each
other has pushed us forward
technologically demonstrating our
incredible Ingenuity as Engineers many
ancient bridges are still in use today
such as the melish river bridge in ismir
Turkey which is nearly 2900 years
old but if we were going to build
Bridges between continents where would
we build them from New York to London
from Sydney to Singapore or what about a
bridge between Russia and Alaska over
the bearing
straight could we possibly build a
bridge between continents and if so what
would it take to build it there are so
many different types of bridges we could
build to connect two continents but with
so many important shipping routes by sea
we'd have to allow boats to pass
underneath we'd probably want to build a
railway as well to maximize the
usefulness of such long Bridges this
could be beside a road or below it the
bridge would need a huge number of
supports to withstand the weight of
thousands of vehicles if we were to to
say build a bridge between San Francisco
and Yokohama Japan some of the supports
would have to be built as deep as 5,000
m to sit on the ocean floor the bridge
itself would have to be
8,292 km long to put things in
perspective California's Golden Gate
bridge between San Francisco and saalo
which is just 1284 M long took 1 million
tons of concrete just to build the
anchorages the massive blocks that
gripped the Bridge's supporting cables
it took 130,000 km of galvanized steel
for the support cables to build a bridge
between Japan and California would be
6,478 times longer and almost 33 times
deeper than the Golden Gate Bridge if we
used the same bridge design to get to
Japan we'd be looking at roughly
488 billion kg of Steel just for the
support cap
Okay so we've done some of the math
maybe a bridge between the United States
and Japan isn't the best option but a
bridge between Russia and Alaska over
the bearing straight might be
technically feasible some people have
suggested building an InterContinental
Railway for $100 billion that would
include a 95 km tunnel under the bearing
straight to connect Russia and Alaska
even if they could raise the money we'd
have to consider factors such as the
environmental imp
and even politics but if they changed
the plan to building over the bearing
straight workers might need to be
stationed on oil rigs along the way and
construction could be affected by
dangerous weather the construction could
also affect the ecosystem in the ocean
and once the bridge was built there
wouldn't really be enough traffic to
make it worthwhile but what if we built
a longer bridge over an ocean the
longest bridge we've ever built is
China's danyang kunang Grand Bridge
spanning
[Music]
need gas stations rest stops hotels
garages hospitals even police stations
and unlike a typical road trip you'd get
pretty bored by the scenery which would
be kilomet upon kilomet of concrete and
water don't expect any fun landmarks
along the way although you might see a
whale or two we even thought of building
a chain of bridges from Northern
Territory Australia through various
Islands to Singapore however with the
the majority of the Australian
population living in the South most
Australians would likely prefer to fly
instead of the long drive to the
north this series of bridges would also
be incredibly expensive to build and
require a huge amount of people
resources and time you can just imagine
the fees to drive across one of these
incredibly long Bridges plus the cost of
gas and meals and hotels the long and
short of it is that we probably won't be
bu Building Bridges across our
oceans Hold On Tight turn up the
elevator music and get ready for a whole
new mode of space exploration forget
rocket launches we already use elevators
to bring us to extreme Heights in our
tallest buildings so why can't they take
us just a little further into space but
wait how much would that cost do we even
have the kind of Technology needed to
make that possible and what would we
gain by building a space
elevator this is what if and here's what
would happen if we built an elevator to
space would you like to take a cheap
vacation to space well you might be in
luck because although the construction
of a space elevator would be incredibly
expensive eventually it would make space
travel much more affordable and open up
a world of opportunities but scientists
tell us that there would also be a slew
of technological logistical and
political hurdles to overcome would it
even be worth
it every elevator needs a starting point
and a destination so to make our space
elevator the first thing we'd need to do
is launch a satellite or destination way
up into the sky but how tall would our
lift need to be well as of right now the
tallest structure we've ever built is
the Burge Khalifa in Dubai which stands
at
8298 m in order to create a successful
space elevator it would have to be at
least
35,7 186 km tall that's more than 40,000
times taller than anything we've ever
built besides the obvious necessity of
leaving our atmosphere the reason the
space elevator would have to be so tall
is to reach something called
geostationary orbit this is the point
where an object's natural orbit exactly
matches the speed of rotation of the
earth below it reaching this orbit would
ensure that our Elevator Shaft always
remains straight and our destination
never moves relative to where we
launched from our next step would be to
lower a cable or Ribbon from the
satellite and attach it to our starting
point back on Earth clamp to the cable
would be a form of elevator car that
would carry people or cargo up and
down if we can successfully pull this
off it would completely revolutionize
space exploration right now our primary
means of getting to space are rockets
and Rockets are expensive at current
prices it costs about $20,000 to send
one kilog into space to put it in
perspective that means approximately
$1.3 million to send an average human up
there after construction the cost of
sending 1 kg into space with a space
elevator would be reduced to just
$200 if we set up a space station at the
top of the elevator we'll be able to
launch all our missions from there and
not have to worry about the costs that
are usually involved with propelling out
of our atmosphere on top of easy
traveling a space elevator would also
open up some new energy
possibilities if we place giant solar
panels along our ribbon they could
collect far more energy than panels on
Earth and radiate it back at low cost
this all sounds good in theory but it
also comes with a lot of obstacles the
main one is the ribbon that connects it
all it has to be light affordable and
more stable than any material we can
produce right now if we don't wait for
the right material our ribbon could snap
and that would be very dangerous if it
breaks near the base the force applied
to the satellite will cause the whole
thing to rise into space and if it snaps
near the to the top the ribbon will fall
wrapping around the world and creating
dangerous space
debris so as tempting as it may be to go
all in on the space elevator right now
maybe we'd best wait until we're able to
do it right imagine what it would be
like if you could wake up in your New
York City Apartment at 7:00 a.m. and
make it to your job in London England by
9:30 in the morning that would be a
possibility if we dug tunnels between
the two continents just try not to get
sick believe it or not something like
this is possible but how would we make a
tunnel like this and how much would it
cost this is what if and here's what
would happen if we dug tunnels between
continents that's right a tunnel like
this is possible I mean a tunnel that's
similar to this already exists it's
called the Channel tunnel or Chunnel and
in just about 35 minutes you can drive
from England to France
without it you'd have to take either a
ferry or a plane compared to what we'd
be building the Chunnel is Tiny at just
over 50 km our tunnel would be over
5,500 km if we wanted to go from New
York to London so how would we make our
tunnel let's use the channel tunnel as
an example of what our tube might look
like to give us some context the channel
tunnel took 6 years to build and it also
took Decades of planning before that as
for the price
if we were to build another Chunnel
today it would cost a whopping $13
billion okay now multiply these numbers
by 100 as that's how much bigger our
tunnel would be and you get the idea
this thing would take an incredibly long
time and would cost a ridiculous amount
of money but let's assume we've got all
this covered and we have unlimited time
and money just because we have enough
resources doesn't mean we should be
stupid in how we use them if we tried to
avoid all the water and when underneath
the seaf Flor we'd have to bore through
the ground from England all the way to
America this would take an incredibly
long time and there's always the
possibility that the tunnel we built
more than 5,000 m underwater would cave
in from the ocean pressure instead the
best way to make the tunnel might be
like this you would make one massively
long 5,500 km tube and put it over the
ocean then using anchors you would drag
the tube down about 45 M you would then
secure the tube using wires tied to the
ocean's floor okay now that we have our
tunnel what do we fill it with will we
drive through it that's so 21st century
instead we'll be taking a train I know I
know that might sound even more old
school than using a car but this won't
be just a regular train to travel
through our tube so quickly we'd need to
use vac trains this system would
essentially act as a vacuum that would
take all the air out of the tube this
would allow the train to travel at
incredibly high speeds due to there
being little or no air resistance not
only that but our train would also be
levitating using high-powered magnets or
with air kind of like an air hockey
table where myc Canadians at after
propelling the train forward with a
high-powered engine it could cruise for
hundreds if not thousands of kilometers
since there's no friction to stop it
with this little resistance the VAC
train can go up to 8,000
kmph but we won't be going that fast as
that could be incredibly dangerous not
just for the train but for your physical
well-being instead you'd be going about
2,000 km which is almost double the
speed of sound but don't be too alarmed
by this your body should be able to
handle it just fine after all the
Concord passenger jet flew this fast for
years before it was decommissioned
so it is possible that we'll see a pipe
that connects across the Atlantic Ocean
one day as long as we have enough money
time and
resources now imagine that the
supersonic train actually exists and we
could casually travel from Europe to
America in just under an
hour think about how industry our
economy and travel would
change 71% of the earth's surface is
covered with water
why don't we make use of all that
underwater real
estate what would it be like to live at
the bottom of the ocean where would we
get oxygen to breathe and food to eat
and what would we do in case of an
emergency
evacuation this is what if and here's
what would happen if we lived
underwater there is one thing standing
between us and underwater living our
bodies aren't adapted to it if you Dove
150 M underwater without proper training
or equipment your lungs would shrivel to
the size of a pop can and your veins
would collapse descending all the way to
the bottom of the ocean would feel as if
you were being crushed under 14 full
cement
trucks but that doesn't mean our dreams
of underwater living can never come true
it just means we'd need to dream smaller
our underwater habitats would be rather
small populated with a few thousand good
Swimmers at
most we'd live in small modules made of
steel glass and cement designed for
underwater use and instead of going too
deep into the ocean we'd settle about
100 m under sea we'd need to build life
support systems that would maintain air
composition temperature and humidity
keeping a livable amount of oxygen in
the air would be our major concern if we
want wanted to make our habitat self-
sustaining we'd need to figure out how
to grow plants that would produce their
own
oxygen how would we go about powering up
our oceanville with land-based solar
panels that would transmit energy to the
habitat we could also use wave power the
undersea equivalent of wind
turbines then there's food we'd rely
heavily on dehydrated and canned
supplies but don't forget about good old
fishing with so many foods swimming in
front of you why not take advantage of
the fresh Sea
Market our drinking water would be
supplied through distillation or
condensation and all our waste would
most likely be flushed out into the
ocean underwater living isn't without
its dangers though imagine a worst case
scenario your bedroom window gets a
massive crack and water Rampages through
your living space or your life support
system fails leaving you to suffocate
under sea in order to stay safe we'd
need to perform regular evacuation
drills and make sure our emergency alert
systems were up and running at all times
you'd be wise to keep an oxygen tank on
hand and have a small submarine ready to
shuttle you to safety the cool thing
about all this is that we already have
the technology to make it work although
so far the longest an individual has
managed to live underwater is 31 days
there are companies out there planning
on building an underwater city like this
whether it's safe enough is another
question today on what if we're going to
build the highest bridge on planet Earth
welcome to the Ching haai Tibet Plateau
the roof of the world it's home to the
world's tallest mountain Mount Everest
but also the longest deepest canyon on
the planet the yarom zangbo Grand
Canyon this super Canyon is 5 5 km long
and 6 km deep and it's here that we'll
be taking on one of the most epic
engineering Challenges ever building a
bridge so high it could take your breath
away
literally for inspiration let's take a
look at how our project would compare to
the world's current tallest bridge
China's Bay Penang bridge this huge
concrete cable stage structure carries
people
1341 M across the Bayan River but even
at a dizzying height of
565 m above the river it would find
itself in a very distant second place
our Bridge would be over 10 times higher
so let's get
started standing face to face with the
deepest canyon in the world you'd be so
high above the rivers below you that you
could stack seven of the world's tallest
skyscraper the Burge Khalifa on top of
each other or the entirety of Mount
Kilimanjaro but the air you'd be
breathing would have less than half of
the oxygen available at sea level while
working on this gravity defying Bridge
you could suffer from high altitude
illness this would make breathing
difficult cause headaches and make you
feel laded you and your crew should
carry oxygen to be safe if you got dizzy
and fell you drop straight through
several different
ecosystems from snowy mountain peaks to
temperate coniferous forests to
subtropical
rainforests all in 35
seconds adding to your already full
plate of design challenges you'd be
surrounded by tall dangerous mountain PE
and your job would be to connect two of
these mountains
numara and
Jala they stand a staggering 22 km apart
this would mean that not only would our
Bridge be 10 times higher than the bay
pangang it would also be about 16 times
longer but just like that one cable
stage suspension would be the best
design option
all you'd need would be massive cables
of tightly braided steel wires they'd
rest on top of towers anchored to either
side of the bridge a suspension bridge
like this would also be the best way to
go because it would be better at
withstanding
earthquakes and the Tibetan Plateau is a
region that is highly prone to
earthquakes but that wouldn't be the
only force of nature you'd have to
concern yourself with you'd also face
severe weather your crew would need to
deal with Fog rain and freezing
temperatures and then there's the wind
Your Design would require the bridge to
be as light and as flexible as possible
but you'd need to make sure it remains
stable even in the most extreme winds
one solution would be to build pendulum
like devices onto each Tower to balance
any swaying or you could construct a
stabilizer fin beneath the center of the
roadway that would keep movement to a
minimum but enough about the ways
weather could affect our Bridge what
about the ways our Bridge could affect
the weather all of this Uber engineering
would be underway in a region that's a
diverse habitat for many plants and
animals one of the factors in this is
the Steep vshape of the canyon it helps
funnel warm moist air North from the
Indian Ocean up to the plateau our
Bridge would need an entire
infrastructure to meet construction
demands your crew would start by
building roads that climb up the
mountains and then working from both
sides at the same time like during the
construction of California's Golden Gate
Bridge you'd bring them together in the
center all of this could definitely
impact the very important flow of air in
the
region and you need to make sure that
the construction process doesn't destroy
the habitats of Wildlife life like the
Bangladesh tiger the be monkey or the
giant boa constrictor would it be worth
it and is there any way to calculate the
final price tag for a project so huge
and with so many
challenges well given that this is 16
times bigger than the bay panang it
could cost upward of 2 billion doar at
the very least but that would be pretty
cheap compared to an even more daring
feat of engineering a highway in
space in a world exhausted of fossil
fuels solar panels can provide a
sustainable solution to our energy
problems but they also come with a
couple of issues for one solar Farms are
massive and they have to be set up
somewhere that gets a lot of sunlight
now if only we had a large mass of
unused land that gets guaranteed
sunlight every day h
H could we cover an entire desert in
solar panels would that be enough to
power the entire world this is what if
and here's what would happen if we
covered the Sahara desert with solar
panels if we covered just 1.2% of the
Sahara desert in solar panels we could
harness enough power to meet the energy
needs of the entire world how would we
overcome the geopolitical and financial
obstacles involved and how could this
project thoroughly change the desert's
climate usually a solar farm is built to
prevent changes in the environment but
if we built one in the Sahara it might
cause some changes of its
own if we line the desert floor with
giant solar panels it would double the
rainfall in the region and increase
vegetation cover by about 20% sound a
little unbelievable well let me explain
Saharan sand is unusually Light In Color
which means it tends to deflect a lot of
light and heat back up into the air if
we covered the sand in dark solar panels
it would mean that more sun would be
absorbed and the ground temperature
would increase warmer air rises to areas
in the atmosphere where it's cooler and
moisture there condenses and Falls as
rain before you knew it one of the most
extreme climates on Earth would undergo
a significant makeover so if these solar
panels would not only provide
sustainable energy solutions but also
add much needed Greenery to our largest
desert then what are we waiting for
shouldn't we be out there building these
things already well it's a little more
complicated than that for one thing it's
great to produce enough energy to power
the world but then you have to worry
about how you're going to get it to
everyone the most likely place this
energy would travel to first is to
Europe exporting sustainable energy
would do great things for a lot of
African economies but would they have
the means to do it currently electrical
grids in Africa aren't very reliable and
they'd need power lines of around 800 to
3,000 km to get where they needed to go
transporting power over long distances
leads to power loss of up to 10% which
means that an already expensive project
would get even more pricey and where
would all the money come from Africa is
home to quite a few unstable governments
the kind that raised some pretty big red
flags with investors of multi-billion
dollar projects like this one on top of
that this would be a long-term project
so there'd be a lot of moving parts
several countries would have to be
involved and any one of them might see a
changing political landscape over the
years that could disrupt or put an end
to the whole
thing as great as this project would be
it would probably be better to attempt
it on a small scale
[Music]
first it's one of the most dangerous and
mysterious places on
Earth it's home to dozens of sunken
ships plane crashes and dead people
it's known as the Bermuda Triangle and
it's shrouded in
mystery so what would happen if we
decided to dump our trash into
it where would it
go and what Mysteries would we solve by
doing
this this is what if and here's what
would happen if we dumped our trash into
the Bermuda
Triangle the 1.3 million square km of
ocean that is the Bermuda Triangle goes
from Florida to Puerto Rico and then all
the way to Bermuda since the 1800s there
have been nearly 1,000 reported
incidents of people mysteriously
disappearing in the area ranging from
small Bush planes carrying just two
passengers to ships 150 M long carrying
over 300
people so if we decided to put our trash
here would that disappear as
well before we even think of dumping our
garbage into the Bermuda Triangle we
first need to figure out exactly how
we'd get
there naturally we'd take a boat as
we're going to dump our trash into the
sea and a boat would allow us to carry
more and be more accurate as to where we
want it to
go now you might be thinking that this
is an incredibly risky move going right
to the center of the Bermuda Triangle
are you insane but there's a pretty good
chance that we'll be just
fine there's a number of theories some
good and some bad as to what really
happens in the Bermuda Triangle is it
some crazy alien portal that's abducting
all our humans is there a massive
underwater city that's underneath it or
is there a scary sea monster living in
it as fun as these theories may sound
they're all incredibly far from the
truth sorry about that one of the more
plausible theories we have about the
Bermuda Triangle disappearances has to
do with methane explosions the theory is
that these methane explosions come up
from the ocean floor and erupt so
violently that they're able to tip even
the most massive
ships but since this theory has been
proposed physicists as well as ocean
experts have debunked it they've said
there's virtually no chance of a methane
explosion being big enough to topple
over a boat and if there was a massive
explosion there's a good chance the ship
would survive that's because boats are
built to handle massive changes in the
water including huge waves and even
methane
bubbles so now that we're here with our
trash we can finally dump it but now it
seems to be just floating there living
in the ocean where's the giant sinkhole
that makes all our trash magically
disappear you know the same place that
taken all these planes and boats over
the years well it turns out that the
Bermuda Triangle isn't all that
dangerous sure it may be a little
mysterious but all these disappearances
can be attributed to severe weather
massive waves and human
error the Bermuda Triangle isn't even
the most lethal body of water in the
world that title can be given to the
oceans in East Asia and Australia and
although nearly 1,000 deaths in the past
200 years might seem like a lot it
really isn't when you consider the fact
that the Bermuda Triangle is one of the
most heavily traveled areas of ocean and
sky in the world so sure we'll need to
watch out for any hurricanes and big
waves but that'll be the least of our
worries for now we just dumped tons of
trash into the ocean we thought that
maybe the Bermuda Triangle would somehow
get rid of it this was a really dumb
idea unfortun Al what we just did
probably won't even be all that
noticeable in the sea an estimated 14
billion tons of trash is thrown into the
ocean every
year let's say we threw all of New
York's trash for a year into the Bermuda
Triangle that's 14 million tons of
garbage it might sound like a lot but it
would only be a tiny fragment of the
rest of the trash that's tossed into the
ocean each year this was a pretty
terrible idea and definitely not one
that should be attempted and it's not
for our safety but for the safety of our
ocean instead of adding to the problem
we should be helping to solve it by
doing our best to clean the ocean ah the
good old days before electricity did we
actually have it better before the first
Power Plant started running what if
everyone on Earth tried getting by with
all their lights turned off we'd start
the challenge with a perfect Earth hour
60 Minutes of complete darkness no
artificial light allowed would weed ruce
the light pollution enough to be able to
see the Milky Way in the night sky how
much electricity would we save would it
help us fight climate
change this is what if and here's what
would happen if everyone on the planet
switched off their lights for an
hour Humanity has spent the last 100
years increasing our dependence on
electricity look around your computer
microwave fridge elevator traffic lights
public transportation everything relies
on electrical power going complet
completely without power even for an
hour would be pretty uncomfortable so
let's just limit Humanity's light usage
Hit the lights and let's begin on
average Humanity consumes 62,000 ter of
electricity per hour that's how much
energy your gas powerered car would need
to drive to Pluto and back twice 1/5th
of all this energy goes towards lighting
that's a lot of energy and producing it
means spewing a lot of carbon dioxide
into the atmosphere obviously clean
energy from the Sun wind and water don't
affect CO2 concentration in the air but
they only make up onethird of global
electricity production the rest of it
releases greenhouse gas
emissions the thinking is if we gave our
power plants an hour break we'd
significantly reduce those CO2 Emissions
on a global level what an easy way to
fight climate change together or is it
turns out it's rather complicated if
this worldwide earthour caught you at
night getting by with the light of some
cozy candles is not the best idea not
only are they 100 times times less
efficient than your light bulb but guess
what they also emit CO2 in theory you
can even the score by using just one
candle for every light bulb you turned
off but if you lit up twice as many
candles you'd actually be emitting more
CO2 what if you didn't light any candles
you might think we'd emit less carbon
dioxide into the air but you'd be wrong
again that's not how power plants work
the Cal burning ones would in fact emit
less CO2 during the dark hour but then
everyone would turn their lights back on
for power stations this sudden increase
in demand would mean firing up more
generators as a result they would emit
even more CO2 and this extra carbon
waste would start to trap more heat in
our lower atmosphere possibly speeding
up climate change and that's if power
plants were able to cope with such a
rapid increase in demand in a worst case
scenario they'd need to perform an
emergency shutdown leaving us with no
electricity for days when that happened
you would at least get to enjoy a view
of the Milky Way at night a view that
light pollution prevents onethird of the
world's population from seeing so maybe
you shouldn't plunge yourself back into
darkness there are better ways to fight
climate change than turning off all the
lights at the same time for starters you
could try replacing all your
incandescent light bulbs with compact
fluorescent ones or take public
transportation more what do you do to
reduce your carbon
footprint
imagine an ultimate road trip across the
globe on a highway along the
Equator wait there there's no Highway
along the Equator
yet so how about we build
one what would it take to construct the
longest road on
Earth how long would you spend behind
the wheel to complete this Epic Journey
and why would building this highway
upset
environmentalists this is what if and
here's what would happen if we built a
road around the
world there are about 64 million kilm of
all kinds of Roads around the globe but
no single Highway Network that can take
you from New York directly to Cape Town
the hypothetical freeway that we're
about to build would easily take you
from Colombia all the way to Indonesia
combine that with some of the existing
Road systems and you might just be able
to drive anywhere in the
world but that would be a very expensive
engineering achievement because a big
part of this highway would have to be
constructed
[Music]
underwater on average it takes about 5
to 10 years to build a highway but we
wouldn't be building just any Highway we
are aiming for a 40,000 km long 2-lane
equatorial road to construct it in about
the same time frame as a normal Highway
we need to be working on different parts
of it all at the same
time our globe spanning Highway would
require about 8 million skilled work ERS
and some 9.2 trillion to build yeah
those are some whopping numbers to
consider and what would it be like to
drive on
it I'd say it's pretty cool the equator
cuts through 13 countries and three
oceans let's say you start in South
America in Ecuador and travel east
through Colombia to
Brazil you'd be enjoying a humid
tropical climate climate and very high
temperatures so make sure your car's air
conditioning is working before you leave
for the
trip you'd be passing over Mountains and
the Amazon River and if you decided to
go for a refreshing swim remember that
the Amazon's full of bloodthirsty
piranhas waiting to eat you in a matter
of
minutes just joking piranas are actually
calm scavengers so you can go for a swim
at your own risk
your Amazonian Adventures would just be
the beginning you would soon reach the
Atlantic coast of Brazil and you'd be
about to enter the First underwater
stretch the Great Atlantic
tunnel and the view here is rather
dull finally there's
land after days of travel you would make
it to Africa you'd be driving through
the savanas swamps and dense rainforest
of gabang and Congo and into the deserts
of Kenya and
Somalia on your way you might see
elephants gorillas buffaloes and
leopards and that would make the long
trip through the tunnel kind of worth it
but then you run out of land and you
enter another underwater tunnel This
Time It's the Great Indian tunnel
h